Here again is our remove html markup program.
If we invoke html markup with s being a single quote
followed by a less-than sign, it passes.
However, if it's a double quote followed by a less-than sign, it fails.
So, this difference in the original input determines
whether the run passes or fails.
Let's go and execute the program a bit further but stop execution
when the loop head is reached for the second time.
Now again we can examine the state.
The variable s stays unchanged at this point.
The character c is still the first character being processed.
Which is different?
In the passing run, it's a single quote.
In the failing run, it's a double quote.
The variable tag is false in both cases.
The variable quote is different.
In the passing run, it is false.
In the failing run, it is true.
In the passing run, the out variable contains a single quote.
Whereas, in the failing run, the out variable is empty.
What you see at this point is that four variables, namely s, c, quote, and out,
all have different values.
You can now imagine that if we were in the passing run,
and we would set these four variables
to the values found in the failing run,
then we would effectively make the passing run a failing run,
meaning that these four variables,
which defer, make up a cause for the failure.
However, it suffices to set only a subset of these variables
to the values found in the failing run.
Only a subset of these variables need to be changed
in order to cause the assertion to fail,
and therefore, the entire run to fail.
So, here is a quiz.
Which of these four variables can be set to values from the failing run
to make the passing run fail?
Is it s--is it c--is it quote--is it out,
or is it a combination of multiple variables?
Hint: If you said all four, this is the correct answer.
What I want is a minimum set of variables.
Over to you.